The narrator of Bridgerton
is Julie Andrews.
The great Julie Andrews.
Yes.
And I know, I mean, the word
icon doesn't even do justice
to who Julie Andrews is,
and what she's accomplished.
I know.
Because she's the narrator of the show,
have you had a chance to meet her?
I haven't, I haven't.
And it's haunted me ever
since the pandemic started.
I actually read her
autobiography in lockdown,
because I just wanted to be close to her.
I was so disappointed
we didn't get to meet,
so I just found out everything I could
about Julie Andrews so that now
I feel like I know her.
And if we ever meet in person
I have something to talk to her about.
Although I worry that
might scare her away.
So I might play it a bit cooler.
Yeah, sometimes that frightens people,
when you say--
Yeah.
When you say, 'oh, you know,
Phoebe meet Julie Andrews.'
'You were born in Leeds in
1928, you weigh 135 grams.'
You know, you don't want to say
that kind of stuff to people,
it sounds creepy.
No.
I have to tell you, I've
been very fortunate,
over a long career, I've been able to meet
just about everybody.
Never had the chance
to meet Julie Andrews.
But they have something
here in the States,
the Macy's Day Parade,
which is a big deal on Thanksgiving.
And I was in New York once,
just before I left about 10 years ago.
And the Macy's Day Parade was going by,
and I was holding my daughter,
who was just a baby at the time.
And suddenly right in front of me,
Julie Andrews goes by on top
of the parade float waving.
I dropped daughter practically,
and started screaming,
"Julie Andrews, Julie."
And I think she saw, I don't
think she recognized me.
But she thought, who's that
horrible woman (laughs).
I completely lost it, that's
the effect she has on people.
She does, yeah, she does.
She's basically a royal.